this element is unique in the periodic
table element 117 uu s because it's
never been observed in any form at all
so the fields wild wide open people are
still thinking about which heavy new
atoms can be accelerated together to
make 117 and it seems perhaps that 117
protons and corresponding number of
neutrons is particularly unstable and so
that this arrangement just seems to fall
to bits before it can properly form so
up till now
there's been no observation of it so
it's quite a challenge for scientists in
the future to see if they can make you
us but they've got to make at least one
atom before one can even consider that
the element has ever been observed